foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
fast and reliable Gene synthesis for
optimized protein expression
this webinar is part of the microbiology
virtual week 2022.
I'm Whitney Barnes of Labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is
presented by labrades and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
please visit thermofisher.com
now let's get started
I would like to remind everyone that
today's event is Interactive we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen
we also encourage you to participate in
three poll questions throughout the
speaker's presentation
simply click on your answer when the
poll questions are displayed
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located in the event
platform
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby
and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Claudia
cochini
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr cochini you may now begin your
presentation
good morning good afternoon to all and
bees and thank you for taking the time
to join this webinar today
and before I start with the presentation
I'd like to mention what is the mission
of thermosis scientific which is to
enable our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer and this is
a mission with a particularly proud of
today in these difficult times of a
global pandemic in which Therma Fisher
is helping by developing accurate
diagnostic tools and supporting our
customers in developing new
therapeutical approaches and hopefully
very soon new effective vaccines against
covid-19 for example from Gene Arts
therm official we've been standing along
this year's thousands of genes were
designated for vaccine development
foreign
for today's webinar I will start
introducing Gene synthesis how it works
and how we can facilitate your Discovery
workflow
I will then explain what Gene
optimization is and why it is key for a
successful gene expression and
ultimately for increasing protein
production
I will describe how to effectively join
biosynthetic DNA pieces to build larger
constructs and in particular we will
take a look at experimental datas
obtained when combining strings DNA
fragments and G naught Gibson assembly
technology
in the second part of the webinar I will
focus on protein production especially
on how to boost protein production by
using Advanced tools already available
for you in the market and combining it
with our expertise in producing protein
and finally we will see how to go from
digital sequence to purified protein
using our gene2 protein service which
gives you access to your desired protein
in the amount and quality you need so
you can save time and concentrate on
your actual research
synthetic biology is very powerful and
is connected to many other disciplines
it supports basic research but also
Industrial Research for example through
acceleration of drug discovery
it is key for new therapeutic approaches
like cell therapy or gene therapy for
the production of new antibody for
example for fight against cancer of
course it is possible through synthetic
biology to develop new biotechnologies
and it is also the base for personalized
medicine approaches where based on the
knowledge of the DNA of the patients
you can
basically find new tailored solutions
for
for many diseases and hopefully as we
will see very soon for covid-19
synthetic biology also enables to
develop safe new vaccines and of course
you can think of synthetic biology as
something which goes beyond life science
one example might be data storage in DNA
so the real power of synthetic biology
is that it really gives you access to
any Gene and any protein you want
regardless the origin and complexity of
these and it doesn't matter for which
purpose you need a protein maybe you
need a single protein to study structure
or function or you are in the middle of
the screening process where you're
searching for the right candidates
in all these approaches you can start
and design proteins from scratch and all
you need is an electronic sequence so
you can have access to this entire
workflow just starting with an amino
acid sequence or DNA sequence and what
it comes next is that the sequence is
optimized and I will talk more
extensively about Gene optimization
after Gene optimization then we can
reform a physical DNA template and this
is the gene synths step and what
normally happens next is that the gene
of interest can be subcloned into a
vector and used for your own application
to produce plasmid or you can use as a
master Gene to produce Gene variants of
course we are also able to produce
entirety in libraries
and what happens next with plasma
preparation normally researchers do a
transformation of E coli or they
transact
cell lines mammalian cells for protein
production so this is just an example of
what your Discovery workflow might look
like and what I want to really focus on
today are three aspects Gene
optimization Gene synthesis and protein
expression from mammalian cells you can
think of this workflow like something we
can support you with and you can either
Outsource the entire workflow or just
ask us to support you in taking over
part of this workflow to accelerate your
research
here come official we are considered
experts in writing DNA and we write in
DNA I mean really synthesizing DNA from
scratch
in this process it is crucial to adapt
the DNA to your host organism when we
talk about hydraulicus gen expression
everyone understands the importance of
the current usage since the genetic code
is CS Universal but it is to generate it
so that amino acid can be coded by
different carbons and we know that the
frequency with which currents are picked
is different from in each and every
organism and this correlates with the
amount of Transfer RNA present in the
cell so it is understandable that
current usage influences in the first
place the efficiency of the translation
and process but there are other factors
which really play a very important role
and these are connected to the
structural property of the RNA I think
of GC content or the presence of Cryptid
Supply sites direct repeats RNA
secondary structures and any elements
causing instability of the sequence so
all these factors play really a rule
and can hamper protein expression
so the gene Optimizer technology was
developed at genot by our RT team and
this takes into consideration 20
different parameters to optimize DNA for
expression in mammalian cells and just
to make you clear that this is a very
complex process you can take a look at
this this is an hypothetical DNA
sequence or your wild type gene on the
left side of this slide and this y-type
sequence might contain unfavorable
cotons which are underlined in red and
more favorable codons which are
underlined in green
and now if you imagine to replace all
the red columns by the green cartons
this would be a quite easy process but
this is a simple back translation so you
don't need really a complicated
algorithm to do this operation and this
would not reach the goal which is to
really optimize your Gene for expression
in your heart so the goal is to find a
trade-off between
the current usage and the presence in
this case the absence of those unwanted
motors which I was listing before and
this is what Gene Optimizer technology
is doing
and what this algorithm does is that it
considers all possible current
combination but not in the entire Gene
sequence but it takes a small window of
10 to 20 amino acids and in this small
window it checks all possible current
combinations according to the current
adaptation index
and what happens is that when the first
optimal cotton is found this is locked
down and this the window slides from
five Prime to three prime and the
process is repeated over and over
a second window is also considered to
evaluate the current combination and as
I was mentioning before
Gene Optimizer really pays attention
that these unwanted motives are not
introduced so that protein expression is
not hampered
so this is more or less the principle
with which our technology works and but
I had also just to say that in Optimizer
algorithm works twofold so on the one
hand we have the optimization for
maximal protein expression and on the
other hand we want to minimize the
complexity of the DNA sequence which is
fundamental to have a successful Gene
assembly and really to minimize also the
efforts for us as a manufacturer so and
to increase of course the probability
that your sequence is immediately 100
correct
so
the next step after Gene optimization is
to break up the gene sequence into audio
nucleotides and this is not a trivial
process so we speak here about the
intelligent oligo design and the oligos
are of course partially overlapping and
they are designed in a way that they
hybrid us to one another and they go
together only in the right order
what you see here is a picture of our
Manufacturing
department and of course we synthesize
oligos in large scale but we've been
optimizing a process over the past years
to reduce the scale and to really be
able to synthesize oligo of great
quality with a with a high throughput
process enabling us now to synthesize
over 30 000 oligos per run per day
so what happened next after audio
synthesis is that the articles are
assembled in a gene assembly reaction
and this is kind of similar to PCR
from the three Prime oh the DNA is
standard and the process is done
iteratively so that the full length Gene
is formed and this is then inserted into
our Center production vector or a
customer Vector if possible
and what happens next is that the
plasmid is then transferred into the
cells into bacterial cells
by transformation this is fundamental
not only to get enough plasma DNA of
course we need then to analyze the
single colonies to screen them and then
grow bacteria culture but it's also
fundamental to isolate single plasmid
and make possible that your plasma
preparation is monoclonal
so after current screening
a blasphemy preparation is done and the
plasmid is analyzed by
Next Generation sequencing also here we
are really increasing our sequencing
capacity over the past year so that now
we are able to do 29 000 reads per day
and after we make sure that the sequence
is 100 correct the DNA is dry packaged
and then sent to the customer along with
final documentation
normally using standard Gene synthesis
you can really quickly have access to
your DNA and you can also request an
additional subcloning step so that we
transfer your DNA or Gene of Interest
into for example an expression Vector so
if you go for the standard true
synthesis you can pick one of the over
115 vitrogen expression vectors
and these services
available in just a few days but if
you're interested in really fast cloning
then you you order you can order our
Express cloning and in this case you can
have access to one of the nine in
vitrogen expression vectors listed here
and in some cases for some eligible
customer we are able to take your vector
we adapted to our manufacturing strategy
and then do directly the cloning
experiment into your wish vector
so what I also wanted to mention is the
standard Gene synthesis service will
give you access to a few micrograms of
DNA there's normally five micrograms of
DNA which are delivered to to the user
but we can increase this quantity and
scale up to 20 milligrams you can choose
different Vector different vectors of
course as I was saying but you can also
choose different buffers to do the
plasmic preparation like trees water or
PBS
and of course you have the option to
choose between tubes and plates and we
have additional
services like fill and finish service
where we can alecute the DNA in a small
aliquot labeled for your direct use
other options are to order TSC free
production or a low level of endotoxin
this is crucial to many researchers
doing as a downstream application
transaction of mammalian cells
so
um we talked a lot about Gene synthesis
now and Gene synthesis of course the
most easy way I would say to get access
to your DNA because you you don't need
to do any step in the lab but there is
also another option that is really very
used by researchers especially in a in
the Academia and this is
um
the option to order strings DNA
fragments string CNA fragments are
double-stranded DNA they are done
exactly using the same mechanism as for
Gene synthesis so it starts with a
bioinformatics step Gene optimization
oligosynthesis and assembly
and the only difference is that the
cloning step is skipped so what we
normally do is a log sequencing of this
synthetic DNA like sequencing of a PCR
product and then measuring of the DNA
concentration
and then just dry the DNA and sand it
along with the final documentation so
meaning that there is no Downstream
service
normally this we deliver at least 200
nanogram of DNA but the quantity average
quantity which we ship this 900
nanograms and this service is
doable for DNA in a length comprised
between 150 base pairs and 3
000 base pairs
so the Practical thing of string is that
they not only convenient but they come
really fast in as few as three business
days for the the easy and short version
and what you have to do is if you want
to have access to your clone it's just
you need to take strings clone it in the
vector of interest and then do the
screening process so pick Connie do the
screening and sequencing
so this is what uh make the product a
bit cheaper compared to Gene synthesis
but it's still a great quality
do you know strings are really a
convenient solution to get access to
your synthetic DNA and we know that many
researchers are used to ordered you know
strings even if they need something
larger so what they do is take combined
you know strings together into a larger
construct and if you're interested in
doing that I strongly recommend to use
Gina Gibson assembly and I mean there
are many many tools that Thermo Fisher
makes available to you to clone DNA
examples which are very well known in
any lab are topoklony Gateway cloning
these are very efficient systems and
they are ideal in case of
I would say a single fragment but when
it comes to assembly of many fragments
it really makes sense to look at a
technology which is efficient fast and
and enables you to really clone these
pieces totally scarless and or as we can
say seamlessly and this is the reason
why General Gibson assembly is a perfect
solution in this case
and what I want to highlight next is
that okay Gibson is method which is
um really out there since a long time
and the beauty of this system is that
you don't need any additional
restriction size to add to your insert
or what you what you need to do is make
sure that you have small homologous
region the short regions are between 20
and 40 base pairs in common two
fragments you want to join and in this
picture this homology region are
highlighted in colors
and only by using those homology region
in your fragments and the Gibson
assembly kit you get final product where
you have absolutely no scars and
um
a covalency bound molecule
so the last
um last year we would been developing
kit here during a ginard Thermo Fisher
and the principle is exactly the same
Principle as in any Gibson assembly
technology so the mix contains a
cocktail of enzymes working
contemporarily so we have an external
glaze showing back homologous ants a DNA
polymerase filling the gaps starting
from the three oh free and then a DNA
ligase which seals the DNA Nicks and the
beauty of this is that your
final product is totally covalency bound
and it is suitable to be transformed
into heat component cells but also into
Electro confidence cells
and this is something which is really
important when you build large dnas
since select operation is much more
efficient
compared to heat shock
so the two options we can offer are a
general Gibson assembly Hi-Fi kits and
the ex kit
Hi-Fi I would say is the perfect
solution for
assembly up of up to six fragments it's
a single step reaction it's a isothermic
reaction and it really gives very high
performance cyclonic efficiency and it
also has an interesting application
which I will go through in one minute
and regarding the ex kit this is the
most Rubble sketch and it's a two-step
format and it's suitable not only for
simple cloning experiments but also for
cloning of up to 15 fragments and it
also delivers a very high cloning
efficiency up to 95 percent
so both are available as a single Master
mix or combined with competent cells as
a kit
and in the next couple of slides I want
to show you the results we got by using
those kits in our lab to join DNA
fragments
and in this experiment for example we've
been using 2 KB inserts and we could
join four pieces into pcdna 3.4 Vector
those DNA segments were sharing an
homology region of about 30 base pairs
and what we did after transformation of
electrocompetence cells we picked
colonies and then analyzed them by
Colony PCR where we detected the
transition region between first and
second fragments which is here on the
gel and third and fourth fragment again
here analyzed on a judge phrases and
what we calculated is the cloning
efficiency as the number of colonies
carrying the full length so both PCR
combination over the number of colonies
which we analyzed we did three
independent experiments and as you see
here only the first experiment we got
100 learning efficiency and in three
separated experiments we got an average
chronic efficiency of 96 so I think this
is really good result
for an 8 KB fragment
Hi-Fi kit is really interesting because
it can be used also to join fragments
which originally do not share any
homologous region and this can be really
interesting in many cases for example if
you you want to
have access to a fragment which is
tricky to amplify by PCR because it's
complex or too large you can just cut it
and then make it compatible to your
vector using stitching oligonucleotides
so using basically single strand DNA
functioning as a bridge between your
wanted fragments and the target vector
and you can use this technology even to
assemble pieces so in this example we
joined two fragments which were not
share nemology
with three different oligonucleotides
working as a bridge
another example can be if you need to
introduce the same general strings which
you ordered into different vectors so
you don't need to reorder strings every
time you change Vector you can even
Shuffle fragment with this technique and
so on and since we weren't 100 sure that
we were picking the right oligar
concentration we tried this experiment
in a pretty bright range of article
concentration and as you can see we got
the optimal cloning efficiency using 30
to 45 nanomolar of oligos
but we still obtain a decent result even
using much less and much more articles
meaning that the technology is really
very robust
um in the next two slides I'd like to
take a look at the performance of the ex
kit this is the one which we absolutely
recommend when you're joining many
pieces together in this experiment we
were joining 0.5 KB DNA fragments or
strings
and
we were comparing the performance of the
Gibson assembly with our own generous
cloning kit as you can see in this
picture where we're we're using uh top
10 heat component cells both kit were
doing very good with six fragments but
the performance of the generous cloning
is going down when we pick 8 and 10
fragments on the other hand the generic
Gibson assembly ex is very stable really
providing High cloning efficiency even
with 10 pieces
and when we use that operation we got
even higher cloning efficiency up to
even 90 percent with 10 fragments which
was kind of affected since as I
mentioned before that operation is the
really the method of choice when you're
doing more complex experiments and here
of course we were not comparing with the
generosity Smith cloning kit since in
this case this kit is not suitable
with uh to to be used
with electropriation
so with this I I like to
um quickly wrap up what we said about
the Gibson technology so the combination
between our strings DNA fragments
engineer Gibson technology is very
convenient and fast way to build large
constructs you have full design
flexibility because you can pick any
Vector you want and this is a clear
Advantage compared to other techniques
like tofu cloning or Gateway cloning
where you are restricted to the use of
the vectors which are linked to those
kits so you have also full design
flexibility you can join multiple
fragments and many small fragments or
even a few large fragments so you can
design the experimentary the way you
want and of course you have access to
the GNR optimization technology so you
can optimize the sequence or of your GNR
strings in in a way that they are
perfect for expression in your final
actual exhaust and if you are interested
in those kits and you want to understand
more about how to set up the reaction
and all about the tips and tricks I
recommend you to take a look at white
papers at the term official.com gives an
assembly page
thank you Dr chaconi this brings us to
our first poll
which one below is not a feature of Gene
art assembly Hi-Fi kit
single step format
two-step format
clone up to six fragments in a single
reaction
up to 95 cloning efficiency
I'll give you a moment to select your
answer
which one below is not a feature of the
gene art assembly Hi-Fi kit
single step format
two-step format
clone up to six fragments in a single
reaction
up to 95 percent cloning efficiency
and for our next poll
would you like to be contacted by our
experts from the sales team to help you
make a purchase and get more information
select yes or no
again would you like to be contacted by
our experts from the sales team to help
you make a purchase and get more
information
select yes or no
and our final poll would you like to
receive a quote at an early stage of
your research
you may select yes or no would you like
to receive a quote at an early stage of
your research
yes or no
thank you for your participation
now I'd like to move to the second part
for the webinar which is about writing
proteins and with this I mean
synthesizing protein de novo starting
from an amino acid sequence
so like in case of the gene synthesis
workflow which where we're looking at
before
also in case of the protein workflow you
can decide whether to take advantage of
our expertise in protein manufacturing
and let us perform the entire process or
if you prefer just can you can let us
take over only parts of this workflow so
the materials or time consuming parts
so here a Thermo Fisher Gene art we have
the expertise in doing protein synthesis
in eukaryotic cells and in particular in
mammalian cells and insect cells
and the reason for this is that even
though we know that many scientists are
still use equal are you still using E
coli for protein expression since um E
coli is cheap and fast growing and its
genetic is perfectly characterized
we also know that there are several
drawbacks in using E coli when
expressing proteins of eukaryotic origin
and the reasons are that Nicola is not
possible to make post-translational
modifications such as phosphorylation or
o and and glycosylation for example m
glycosylation is fundamental to produce
functional antibodies
there are also limitation in the size of
the protein that you can produce
and especially for membrane proteins for
example the missing environment really
do not favor the right expression of
those proteins
and also many other proteins do not fold
correctly and they form inclusion bodies
so that the protein cannot be
redistolved and obtained in a functional
in a functional way
so for this reason it is preferable to
express eucerative protein in eukaryotic
cells and also I have to say many of our
customers of Biotech and Pharma they do
research with mammalian cells for many
reasons also for vaccine development
human therapy and Diagnostics
so when we're talking about autologous
Expressions the expression of mammalian
genes in mammalian cells one might ask
the question why should we optimize the
gene for expression
and the reason is simple is that many
projects are not meant to be expressed
at a high level in the South since
nature do not optimize protein for
maximal expression but rather for
optimal regulation
so another reason is of course that by
optimizing genes we can get rid of all
motives that can hamper expression and
reduce at the end the yield of a protein
so examples can be premature
polyadenylation presence of Alternatives
flies inside amarnated stabilization and
any elements causing transcription
transcriptional silencing
so to prove the efficiency of our
mammalian Gene optimization algorithm
our r d scientists did a few years ago a
study which was published
selecting 50 proteins belonging to the
most studied protein classes
these were including protein Kinesis
transcriptional factors ribosomal
proteins cytokines and membrane proteins
each gene was synthesized in two
versions so the y-type and the optimized
Gene for expression in mammalian cells
and after Gene synthesis and cloning
hack 293 cells were transacted in
triplicate to minimize the variance
and then protein yield obtained from
wire type and from optimized Gene were
just compared
and what you see in this picture here
the Western blot analysis of the
resulting proteins and the output was
very positive so in 86 percent of the
cases the optimized genes overperform
the wild-type genes and in 96 percent of
the cases the optimized Gene resulted in
at least equal protein levels compared
to the white type
so it seems that Gene optimization is is
really
um an advantage and increases protein
expression
so what we did next is that we pressure
test it again Gene Optimizer technology
by comparing it with
um analog Technologies offered by our
competitors
and for this purpose a selection of
protein kinases were was taken
also in this case Optimus genes
delivered more protein compared to the
white type and the best result we got it
was a 27 full increase
on a country in case of competitive
methods they failed at least in one
example to provide better yields
compared to the white type so in
conclusion
it seems with Gene art Gene optimization
algorithm for mammalian cells we have a
very good tool in our hands to increase
protein production
so in the next slide I went to I want to
show you how to combine Gene origin
optimization with two other Therma
Fisher tools available for you in the
market to really boost protein
expression
so I'm talking about gibco reagents and
culture media and xb293 nxpial cell
lines
so the gitu media was developed to
enable cells to grow
at a three-time higher density compared
to standard media an xp293 and xp2 are
optimized to grow at high density and
produce more protein per cell so just as
an example xb293 can be transacted at a
density of 3 million cells per
milliliter an XP show at a density of 6
million cells per milliliter
so those two products are available in a
kit along with a highly efficient
transaction reagent which reliably
delivers your clone dni into the cells
so now
it is understandable that the effect is
even improved when when those high
performance systems are compared are
combined with our genotine optimization
method so basically when we transact the
cells with mammalian optimized clone DNA
and this provides approaching yield
increase of three to tenfold
foreign
so using those tools it is very likely
you to obtain the same results we would
obtain in our laboratory when doing
protein manufacturing however there are
many benefits in using our Gene to
protein service
so the service has the advantage to
offer to you a full design flexibility
so you can select any of the vector
present in our in our list on the home
page so more than 115 veteran vectors or
you can send us your own Vector
established in your lab you can choose
along
sp293xpial mammalian system and also sf9
insect cells combined with a buccal
virus dispression system
you can decide the scale of your
experiment the purification method and
of course you can request the customized
processing analysis
so and what is really important to say
is that everything comes from one hand
so there is no need to transfer
material or information from one side to
the other because everything is done
in-house at our site so concerning
protein purification and and concerning
the scale I will just talk about it in
the next two slides so I want to
concentrate now on analysis and at the
beginning when this service was offered
we were able to provide you a standard
analysis such as SDS page or Western
blot and command sustaining and of
course the measurement of the protein
amount but now we are able to
um to also fulfill other requests so you
can request capillary electrophoresis to
determine the degree of purity of your
protein or hboc chromatography to
determine the monomeric state of your
antibody for example or even Mass
spectrometry analysis to check the
efficiency of the glycosylation for your
antibodies so there's plenty of
possibility to really customize this
service
concerning the cells as I was saying
before as the choices between mammalian
cells and insect cells and but I have to
say that xp293 and XP show systems they
are the preferred system from the
researchers ordering our Dental product
and service
capacity is constantly growing so and in
terms of scale we are really very very
flexible so last year there was a a new
product which was launched and this is
the small scale protein service this is
really suitable to customers doing for
example High throughput screening
experiment so researchers who do not
need high amounts of protein but they
need many proteins at once so in this
small scale service we offer 24 to 96
multi-wire expression of course there is
also the possibility to go up with the
scale and have a substantial culture in
30 milliliter or 25 liter and concerning
capacity this is as I was saying
constantly increasing So currently we
can do 300 liter suspension culture cell
per week and additionally 100 liter
in bioreactor culture
so um regarding protein purification as
I was saying before this is also totally
customizable so adaptable to your to
your use
many researchers are interested in
antibodies and I think that more than 80
percent of the protein we purify daily
are antibodies but of course we are able
to produce non-antibody proteins as well
so you can pick any of the Affinity tags
normally used in the lab like hysterics
or ctac
and regarding purification
there's also the possibility to go for
different procedures it can be
customized using different protocols
which you normally take in your lab
different resins or buffers but the
standard process is to start with an
affinity chromatography like kind of
enrichment step
then switch to ion exchange
chromatography and then close with a
size exclusion chromatography which is
the final polishing step so this is just
an hypothetical way to purify your
protein and of course there are also
additional options like getting rid of
the tag using project is cleavage or
using our again field and finish service
early quoting the projecting so that it
is ready for your Downstream application
or even adjusting concentration if you
need and so on
foreign
I'd like to spend the last few minutes
to go even one step further and describe
you the possibility to go not only from
Gene to to protein but also from Gene to
structure so we know that a lot of
researchers are interested in
resolving the structure of the protein
and x-ray crystallography is of course
very very powerful and it has been
improved in the past years but it there
are still bottlenecks in using these
Technologies if one Think Of
crystallization of membrane proteins or
large complexes like in the ribosome and
so forth so for for these cases
cryoelectron microscopy
is is really
um
a valid option and cry iom is so fast
that you can get your protein structures
really in a few weeks instead of a few
months so if you start barely with an
electronic sequence you can get your DNA
in two weeks using our service then
three additional weeks to do
transactional the cell line purification
and then finally you can use try Ram if
you access to this technology to produce
your protein structure
and we did a simple feasibility study
using protein p97 which is an rtps
and use the workflow I was highlighting
before using our Gene optimization Gene
synthesis protein purification and then
after freezing the protein using
basically bringing it to cryoscopic
temperature
what happened next is that in cryov
electrons are fired at copies of Frozen
molecules and an electron deflection is
recorded by detectors and with complex
softwares
the images can be stitched together in
the two-dimensional and then 3D classes
and this is really an exciting process
which is getting better and better and
there is I think a recent publication uh
pointing out that researchers were able
to use cryo-am to get a resolution of
1.25 angstroms which is just amazing
because it means that we are now able to
redefine the position of individual
atoms so in our experiment we were able
to determine the structure of p97 also
in presence of this substrate which is
ATP and you can imagine life or x-ray
crystallography to use this technique to
crystallize your protein in presence in
the presence of the relative substrate
or antagonist or anything so I think
this is an exciting further development
of
protein structure determination is of
course something we're looking into to
be maybe able soon to offer to you a
gene to structure service
I've been talking in detail about Gene
synthesis and protein synthesis services
and products from thermal facial
scientific and I would like to mention
on additional advantage over alternative
providers which is our Customer Support
Network so we assist customers through
our Customer Care Group our technical
sales Specialists and our Global
Technical Support with more than 200
scientists located at 18 different sites
around the globe
and now I'd like to wrap up
the tea takeaways of this webinar are
that Gene synthesis is a Cornerstone for
synthetic biology and enables to produce
genes from scratch giving us access to
any sequence regardless its origin or
complexity
Gene optimization is a complex process
which is key to obtain successful gene
expression in heterogous as you know
thought it was host
constructing large DNA is simple and
convenient if you use genar strings
combined with genar Gibson assembly kit
and this is ideal to construct larger
genes or even entire pathways
and finally the recipe to obtain high
protein yield is to combine genot Gene
optimization and Technology we have
advanced distression systems such as
xp293 and Expo which are the highest
starter systems in the market
so if you want to partner with Thermo
Fisher to accelerate your research
you can reach out to us ing your local
sales representative or visit them
official.com gnart and of course you can
reach out to our customer care team by
sending an email at Gene artsupport them
official.com
and with this I'd like to thank you very
much for your attention and I'm looking
forward to taking your questions
thank you Dr chokini for your time today
and your important research
now before we go I would like to thank
our audience for joining us and I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for sponsoring today's
webinar
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years through September 8th 2023.
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you again for joining us and have
a great day